Picard series three it's coming soon
we've had the big trailer and it looks
pretty cool can this actually be Third
Time Lucky for Picard
[Music]
okay so if you are a regular side
tracking you'll know I'm not a big fan
of the first two seasons of Picard they
actually made me quite angry and for
both seasons I was incredibly excited
the trailers just made the series look
it was going to be exciting
action-packed for what we actually got
was confusing
had horrible mistakes which I'm going to
talk about in a minute and at times was
not well written or executed
the first two seasons of Picard were a
meandrian mess at times and really
really left us disappointed even though
the seasons had highs the first episode
of season two was absolutely fantastic
but those highs could not take away
from the very low lows
so first of all some of the big issues
that I had were the first two seasons of
Picard and now I'm gonna talk about this
because I'm going to make the argument
basically that I think there is a risk
for Picard season three and that risk is
that Terry metallis the guy that has
written a lot of the Picard so far that
we've seen and is now show run in first
season three might have listened to the
fans but potentially maybe he's listened
too much and I think there's a risk that
by pandering to the fans he might have
actually painted himself into a corner
but hey let's talk about some of those
bigger problems and smaller issues from
the first two seasons Picard is an
Android now they kind of ignored that in
the rest of Picard season two you know
actually Q could have gone
dude you're an Android
you're human again but they didn't they
just they just pretended it didn't
happen
but the whole storyline in the first
season was basically basically the
Picard was sick he had this thing and he
said that was incurable and he was gonna
die and then oh Magic oh he's an Android
my main problem for that it was
unnecessary it was stupid and now Picard
is basically really dead
he is now an Android he is a copy he's
not actually Sean Luke Picard anymore
now the fans pointed this out to the
creators of Picard so in season two they
just kind of ignored it and in season
three I'm certain they will continue to
ignore it series one villain now the
whole thing about season one was this
squid thing was going to come through
this portal and was going to destroy the
universe that's what the romulans were
terrified of that was the whole reason
why the fleet turned open the whole
thing with the Androids and everything
the whole storyline was building up to
this incredibly terrifying villain what
we then got was a bit of a hole in space
and some tentacles came out
come on that whole finale was incredibly
underwhelming we had those two enormous
fleets facing off against each other the
Romulan Fleet looked kind of skinny and
the Federation fleet was copy and pasted
it was badly put together
they didn't even shoot at each other
there was this opportunity for this
amazing space battle that they just
didn't bother with and then obviously we
then had the Squiddy things the whole
episode and the whole season one fizzled
out into nothing another big problem is
season one there was no Federation in it
but we got to see some of the Federation
in season two
but that now takes us into the issues
with season two
the whole season was an utter waste of
time
now I actually would argue that there's
only two or three episodes worth of
actual story in that entire season but
they stretched it out for 10. we had
this whole trying to understand why
Picard was the person he is but to be
honest it was forgettable and kind of
stupid the episode where um his dad was
then his shrink it was supposed to be
dramatic and it just didn't work it
missed completely
the whole thing with giratis the ball
Queen We All twigged Around halfway
through the second episode
we and the whole actual series if you
think about it was a complete waste of
time when girati appeared as the bork
Queen she had already had the
conversation with Picard on the
stargazes ready room the conversation
basically was the Picard was tempted to
listen to the Borg now seven of nine was
kill kill kill
Picard was this could be the strongest
Ally the Federation has ever made
we could actually be on the precipice of
an amazing thing now don't get me wrong
the more incredible an opportunity
generally speaking the higher the risk
but Picard was willing to listen
if girati Borg Queen gerati had opened
hailing frequencies and gone dude it's
me I'm from the past I'll explain in a
minute we've got this thing to go and
sort
crack on Picard would have listened
so the whole reason for Q taking him
back in time to make him explore his
feelings and blah blah and make him
maybe then listen to Girardi and not
blow up the ships was a complete waste
of time because he was already willing
to listen to genati
so all of season two is a waste of time
also Q
we were promised and and they teased us
that they might actually explain the
entire cue storyline from encounter at
Far Point Q has said that Humanity was
on trial and that actually Picard
specifically was on trial as well
thing in the trailer and in the first
episode of um season two they teased us
again with he says you're always on
trial this is the final part this is the
last stage of the story not taken
they tease us again and again with that
they're going to explain the whole cue
storyline
and then they just don't
Q wanted to say goodbye to Picard that
final scene was incredible when Q does
say goodbye but the whole time queue is
in the past
does he actually do anything
it's actually very confusing unless
they're going to explain something about
this in season three I don't actually
understand what he was doing with Adam
zung
so
it all seemed to be a bit pointless
there's a couple of little problems as
well the first two seasons Picard and
these things just as a Trekkie they
shouldn't irritate me but they do in the
first episode of Picard season 2 there's
this amazing panning shot of the Golden
Gate Bridge and on the Golden Gate
Bridge there isn't a road anymore
because why would there be nobody drives
cars but instead there's an array of
solar panels
why this is a world of antimatter Power
Systems and um Fusion reactors why on
Earth would they use solar panels on any
industrial scale anyway you would maybe
have some on your roof where you know
you're just powering your lights and you
don't really need anything else you
don't need to be hooked up to a grid
especially assuming that solar panels
would be way better in the future than
they are today but why would they have
an industrial solar panel thing on a
tourist attraction and would be a
national treasure the Golden Gate Bridge
now I think the creators just did that
because they thought it would look cool
and they've maybe been a bit you know
like oh solar panels and global warming
and things but it doesn't make any sense
so don't do it
another thing
and and forgetting the fact that we've
seen the Golden Gate Bridge in Star Trek
before and it's not got solar panels on
but anyway and another thing and this is
maybe a bit more of a gun and I really
don't understand why they didn't do this
all the starships that we've seen in
season two Picard The Excelsior and the
Stargazer in fact don't have a
alphabetic
um designation they're not in they're
not the Stargazer a or the Excelsior b
or the exams you see or whatever like
the enterprise Enterprise a Enterprise B
Enterprise d
we know that the Stargazer is a new
vessel first in its class it should have
an alphabetic designation but it doesn't
but none of the Starships do why
why in this time period all of a sudden
they stop doing that it's just these
little details that kind of bug me and
if anybody out there can explain it I'd
love to understand my biggest problem on
my biggest fear though Picard season
three is that I know terramatalis is
really working hard to do an amazing
show nobody creating the show wants to
do a bad television show and lots of
people that have already seen the first
few episodes are saying that this is
really the Star Trek that we deserve and
the Star Trek that the Next Generation
crew deserve this is going to be the
final hurray for Picard and even though
he's already said he might carry on but
I'm a bit concerned that potentially
Tony metallis and the other people who
have written this series have listened
to the fans and have listened to all
these complaints that I've just
mentioned but while trying to give the
audience what they want could they have
gone too far now I buy this I mean I'm a
bit worried about the fact that Moriarty
is in this series even though we all
sort of went oh my God Moriarty
why and how is he in this series it's
gonna have to be very clever because if
it's not it's just going to be stupid
it's just going to feel like they've
shoehorned in a character from The Next
Generation for the sake of it rather
than it being actually relevant to a
coherent story
we have law and it from the new trailer
it doesn't look like laws necessarily
the villain we've come to know now is it
law or is it before we can't be sure
that rhymes it didn't mean to but hey it
did now to be honest from what we've
seen from the next trailer to me it
makes more sense that it's actually
before
but if it is law he's different and he
has a motion and that's going to have to
also be explained in a very clever way
now they've keeping a lot of Secrets
there's a lot of things we don't
understand but we know there is a big
threat and that that threat is putting
the entire Federation potentially at
risk now everything looks like it's
going to be an action-packed exciting
series and to be honest it looks like
we're going to have a lot of space
battles which makes me very happy again
if you are a regular Sidetrack you'll
know I am a for a space battle oh
man I love it it's just it's awesome so
if they've got lots and lots of Space
Battles I'm going to enjoy the series
but I'm really hoping that while trying
to keep all of us fans happy they
haven't gone too far
and I have to admit
third time looking is me being really
really optimistic I'm really hoping they
can pull something out the bag here
because you know first series
disappointed second series really
disappointed if they disappoint me again
I might actually have to turn my back on
Star Trek altogether
and that would be a massive shame
considering this has been a franchise
that's been with me since I was about
10. they have done a lot of damage to
the franchise of Star Trek in the last
few years
I'm just hoping that Picard season 3 can
repair some of that damage
I'd love to know though guys what you
think are you willing to give them a
third chance
or are you not even gonna bother with
Picard season three I'd love to know
exactly what you think
as always if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you want to become a fully fledged
side tracker please consider hitting
that join button there are links in the
description for our nine Chevron
Stargate website our merchandise Channel
our sister Channel Sidetrack sides and
lots of other things so please go and
check that out as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]